there's something quite nostalgic about
a bald egg it's something that's never
lost it's magically you slice that top
off and dunk mat soldier into the yoke
you can't mess with a deliciously runny
yolk but this is what I like to dunk in
it an anchovy soldier anchovies
interfacer mortar no salt naturally yeah
anchovies are very salty so just a touch
of pepper rich in omega threes the
amazing tinned anchovy is a natural
flavor enhancer and I use it to pepper
many a savory dish from roast lamb to
the humble toasted soldier a really nice
smooth paste the smell of that is almost
like being at the seaside now
get your soft butter I just put half the
butter in first 50/50 is the way piece
of sin anchovy to descend butter that
way but that real nice salty cream let's
mix that up
there's absolutely delicious trust me
finishing that anchovy butter on a slice
of grilled fish I'm in heaven the bread
this is a sourdough delicious a crusty
take four nice slices now get that pan
nice and hot a couple of tablespoons of
that and Chava oil into the pan and then
get your bread and lightly fry each side
the smell the anchovy oil is incredible
take that out now bring your water up to
the boil the secret of softly boiling an
egg is to place him as the water gently
on a spoon in and just tilt so they
don't hit the bottom nice and light up
to the ball count to five turn the gas
down is it four and a half minutes is it
five minutes for softball day I've
cooked thousands of them and every time
it's four and a half minutes boss that's
boiling get your bread and spread that
on there that is incredible chopped
parsley brings that kind of freshness
goes brilliantly well with the anchovies
hear that crunch on in cyber I can't
resist oh my god
right gas off one beauty in - I feel
like a five-year-old again this is that
moment when you open the vault and that
little magic inside is all yours there's
a great twist on a great classic Wow
[Music]
but early softball eggs with dressed up
anchovy butter soldiers who would have
thought that Megan soldiers could be
that delicious
[Music]